in this video we are going to properly
set up and use a balance together before
using a balance you want to make sure
it's properly calibrated the way that
you calibrate a balance is with
pre-calibrated weight standards they
look like this now you want to make sure
that the balance has been plugged in for
about an hour or two before you start
the next step is to level the balance
you do that by turning the dials on the
sides of the balance to make sure that
the bubble is in the center now it's
time to calibrate normally there's a cal
button on the balance some balances have
internal cal and that's fine for daily
calibration for more thorough
calibration we want to do a spanning cow
from here the balance will prompt you to
place pre-calibrated weight standards
place the weights when prompted and
store the values when you're done you
can now use the balance when there's
nothing on the balance you use zero to
zero everything out tear is not zero
tear is only used when something is on
the balance and you wanna remove the
weight of that something use terror when
you wanna weigh something in something
pretty simplistic but you'd be surprised
how many people get that wrong there you
have it that's how you set up and
properly use a balance if you want us to
keep making more videos to help make
your life in the lab easier like and
subscribe
you